this is Jocko podcasts number 153 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening
congressional resolution honoring the
veterans of helicopter attack light
squadron 3 and their families
whereas helicopter attack light squadron
3 here and after in this resolution
referred to as Hal 3 began its history
as detachments of Navy helicopter combat
support squadron 1 hc1 which began
helicopter gunship operations in support
of navy brown water special operations
and army units in the mekong delta of
South Vietnam on September 19th 1966
whereas the detachments of hc1 adopted
the name sea Wolf's whereas Hal 3 was
officially established on April 1st 1967
in Vung Tau South Vietnam and was the
only active duty Navy helicopter gunship
squadron in the history of naval
aviation whereas during the squadrons
existence nearly 3,000 veterans of Hal 3
displayed extraordinary courage in
support of United States military and
political objectives in Vietnam whereas
44 veterans of Hal 3 gave their lives in
support of military operations in the
mekong delta vietnam whereas the
extraordinary performance of the
veterans of hal 3 earned numerous Unit
Citations including six Presidential
Unit Citations seven navy unit
commendations one Meritorious Unit
Commendation a Republic of Vietnam
Meritorious Unit Commendation and the
Vietnam Service Medal whereas the valor
of the veterans of Hal 3 earned five
Navy crosses 31 Silver Stars two legion
of merit medals five Navy and Marine
Corps medals 219 Distinguished Flying
crosses
a hundred and fifty six purple hearts a
hundred and one Bronze Stars a hundred
and forty two Republic of Vietnam
gallantry crosses over 16,000 air medals
four hundred and thirty nine Navy
Commendation medals and two hundred and
twenty eight Navy achievement medals
making it possibly the most decorated
Navy squadron during the Vietnam War
whereas the maintenance and
administrative personnel of Hal 3
contributed greatly to the success of
the nine hal three detachments operating
throughout the mekong delta providing
the detachments with superb maintenance
support and logistics
whereas hal three flew over a hundred
and thirty thousand hours of combat and
logistical support whereas hal 3
inflicted several thousand casualties on
enemy forces whereas hal 3 performed
1530 medical evacuations
whereas hal 3 delivered over 37,000
passengers and over 1 million pounds of
cargo and whereas hal 3 was
disestablished in march 1972 at being
the south vietnam as part of the
Vietnamization program leaving behind it
a combat and humanitarian record
recognizing recognized as bringing great
credit upon the united states navy and
its role in the vietnam war now
therefore be it resolved that the House
of Representative won honors the service
courage and sacrifice of the veterans of
Hal 3 to honors the families of Hal 3
veterans for their support 3 expresses
its condolences to the families and
comrades of those killed in action and 4
recognizes Hal 3 as a unique squadron in
the history of naval aviation
and that resolution of recognition was
made in 2010 actually 38 years after the
Seawolves
were disestablished in vietnam and that
is a long time to wait for recognition
and this is because well for one thing
they weren't looking for recognition but
also to much of the world the sea war
with sea wolves were relatively unknown
for me having grown up in the SEAL Teams
I actually knew about the sea Wolf's I
knew about the reputation from the
Vietnam era seals that held them in the
absolute highest regard possible and
they were considered extremely creative
courageous sometimes beyond courageous
they were incredible pilots and the
highly aggressive Gunners and the teams
that maintained and kept the aircraft
flying in really horrible conditions
they were known for getting the job done
and there's one thing that always stuck
in my mind when I heard stories about
the sea Wolf's in Vietnam and that was
this simply if you called them they
would come and it didn't matter if it
was day or night sunny skies or typhoon
rains a calm extraction or a hot landing
zone filled with enemy fire to the
Seawolves
none of that matter what mattered is
that the troops on the ground needed
help and if you called the sea wolves
they would come and it is an honor today
to have one of these men here with us to
tell us about this relatively unknown
but at the same time legendary squadron
of Naval Aviation helicopter attack
squadron light
hal 3 the sea Wolf's and we have Dennis
rally naval officer naval aviator and of
course Sea Wolf sir absolutely honored
to have you on the show thank you for
coming
chuckle I thank you and you echo for the
opportunity to be here it's it's
something that I didn't want to do you
know you hear the old saw about you
don't talk about the war and I think
that's true of most all of the guys that
I knew and flew and fought with we just
don't talk about it except over a beer
in a bar somewhere with that guys we've
trusted our lives too
however my wife stinky and my son and
daughter when they heard about this
opportunity told me you got to do this
you got a help keep the reputation of
the sea walls alive and I don't think
that reputation he's a lot of buildup on
my part that I'm here to honor the 44 of
our brothers who weren't able to come on
back with us and I'm here to help share
a little bit of history about the
squadron and I'm here to thank every one
of you swinging dick Gunners who helped
me get my little pink body back without
any additional holes in it those guys
are phenomenal I mean they're really
something but we'll get into that it's a
pleasure to be here I'm looking forward
to the conversation I'm still a scratch
in my head as to why I'm here because
you guys have giants on this show
you just had a fella who was a highly
decorated marine infantry officer he
went on to get a law degree he went on
who work in the VA he became the
Secretary of the Navy he became a
congressman from the great state of
Virginia and oh by the way was a
little-known candidate for president of
the US and party politics aside this
kind
would have been better off if Jim Webb
had been our president totally agree
yeah and I can say that not from you
know just a casual reading of his bio I
know Jim because it was a classmate of
mine at the Naval Academy I know Jim
because it was a company made of mine at
the Naval Academy and I know Jim to be
the the kind of a man that I would hope
my son would become just a great guy
I can also say that I know Jim because
for a brief time plebe summer we roomed
together so you're looking at one of the
only guys that you'll ever meet who is
proud to share the fact that he slept
with the Secretary of the Navy so yeah
we're here to spread the word and have a
little fun
via the one thing that was really
important about recent past is a Seawolf
reunion we have reunions every every
couple of years and now many reunions
more frequently but this one who is
pretty special
it was about two months ago we were
gathered on the flight deck of the
Midway for the premiere of a documentary
called scramble the Seawolves they had a
big inflatable screen on the flight deck
and we were all up there laughing and
scratching one thing that I noticed
about the entire experiences man OVAs
guys look old but the the movie with the
documentary was very well shot it's
actually being released on KPBS and PBS
and I assume that shortly after that'll
be available on YouTube but it it gave
us a sense of pride and I think I can
speak for everyone that it gave us a
little greater sense of belonging based
upon the fact that our story could now
be told yeah no that's a I've watched it
anybody can watch it you can give you
Google scramble the Seawolves KPBS it'll
pop up and you can watch it just you
know there's no email to sign up for
it's free that's how you can you can
watch it
let's let's talk about the seal so let's
talk up a little bit about your past cuz
I think you're I mean starting with your
your dad being a pilot and now let's
start with that and and what that was
like growing up well my dad would really
be pissed off at you for calling him a
pilot because dad was an aviation
ordnance chef and he knew that the guys
in the back were doing the job and the
guys up front were just uh steering the
bus no my dad William John Rowley was a
hell of a guy he was an interesting man
and that's the nicest thing you can say
about somebody I think dad was a kind of
a guy who could walk into a room and
full of strangers in an hour later walk
out and everybody thought to is their
new best friend good guy great guy but
he comes from a long line of warriors my
grandfather who married my grandmother
from Hilo yeah yeah he fought in World
War one I have a wonderful picture at
home of my mom and her three brothers
taken during World War two and uncle
Walt is there in his Marine Corps
uniform Uncle Bob is there in his navy
blues and my my Uncle Jim is there in
his army airforce uniform yeah and then
when world war ii broke out my my dad
and his brother my uncle herb both
joined the Navy dad went on into
aviation ordnance and came out the other
end of the the pipe after peace is one
of the last of the Tojo Chiefs a guy who
made chief in a little over three years
yeah he's an interesting fellow
and leadership lesson number one for me
was the way he helped me grow as I was
coming up you would think that a chief
petty officer in the Navy can be very
gruff and directive and they can and
they are when it's required the dad
never told me go do this he'd say have
you ever considered have you ever
thought about have you ever and he
brought it into practice one day when I
was just getting
ready for college and trying to decide
where I was going to go he had just come
back from a Med Cruise and he had one of
his Jos a pilot a Naval Academy grad I
invited me over to his house for dinner
I know I thought that was a little
strange but I was pretty excited about
it the guy came and picked me up in a
brand-new yellow Corvette and took me
over to his home and introduced me to
his drop-dead gorgeous Swedish wife and
how dad didn't have to say you should go
to the Naval Academy for the experience
in learning leadership he brought it
down to a level that I could understand
yeah I thought you'd get issued a
Swedish wife yeah well actually what I
wanted Jocko was so somebody five eight
five nine long straight blond hair good
dad bitchin bod would he come completely
intelligent and imbued with the mating
instincts of a wild mink in heat and
what the good Lord saw fit to pair me up
with was stinky and she's a stumpy
little brown haired girl that's just
ornery as a sack a wild guess so yeah
ain't it funny how it all works out so
so you you you go meet this pilot and
you did that did that flip the switch in
your head well I always knew I wanted to
be a naval aviator it's just something
that I what I wanted I had initially had
dreams of going in and flying spats that
day one was a just a hell of a weapons
carrier and a close air support mission
that was nonparallel in my way of
thinking they got a lot of guys out of
the ship but that didn't work out
because the aircraft was being retired
as I was going through flight school the
thought of going to the Naval Academy
was always intriguing to me I didn't
know that I'd be able to make that but I
was one of the you know I'm sort of
large and I was a one of the only Navy
dependents who were into athletics and
Kubasaki high school on Okinawa where I
went through all four years of high
school and the senior naval officer on
the island had roomed with
the football coach at Navy they did a
quick Scout and told me to take up a
competitive exam and I'd be considered
for the Academy I had had a year to
waste while I was waiting to get into
the Academy so I went to Berkeley this
is in the 1963-64 school year which was
very colorful Mario salvo was up there
doing his is a dirty word movement on
the steps of the administration building
was it was ugly my parents lived across
the hill in Walnut Creek California and
every time the news was over I'd get a
frantic call from my mother are you okay
you okay yeah mom I'm okay it's yeah but
in any rate following that you're at
Berkeley every seat of presidential
appointment and even though he was he
had been assassinated John Kennedy
signatures was on that yeah and I went
back to the to the Tanev II fell in love
with Cru and I can honestly say that if
it hadn't been for rowing at Navy I
probably wouldn't have made it through I
probably would have quit which is
something that you would have been
pissed off about yeah
and why is that because it gave you
something to focus on it gave you an
outlet exactly crew is hands-down the
the greatest team sport that you can
imagine it if even one person is not
pulling their weight is not exactly in
sync the rhythm of the boat suffers
it'll be dragged down and everyone will
know exactly the the reason for that you
can tell by the size of the puddle the
way the boat is set it's it's phenomenal
so it's it's a great lesson in group
leadership and that everyone has to be a
leader in that she'll to put their there
the maximum that they can into it to
make the boat move if you get a chance
for you to book all the boys in the boat
it's a I've heard of that it's yeah it's
got great insight and - what rowing is
all about and you guys should be up on
other
sports and so you you you row at the
Naval Academy and how is your how is
your since you kind of grew up in the
Navy your dad was a chief it must have
been at least somewhat prepared for the
you know the shock and awe of chill
instructors and upperclassmen and all
that stuff
it wasn't the the drill instructors or
the the upperclassmen it was the chicken
ship I had a guy in our company that
just aided me and he'd stand me up in
the passageway and he had a plastic
baseball bat and beat me in the chest
with it yeah it's a non-event
you know funk funk funk but if I saw
that guy again because it was just so
juvenile I was happy years older than my
classmates for a number of reasons I
flunked kindergarten but if any rate it
was yeah you just don't do things like
that there's there's there's no there's
no leadership lessons there's no benefit
to be had from some of the stuff that
was going on in there but when I got out
there on the water with my teammates you
know it all just went away yeah there's
something to be learned from having to
put up with such crap and I think
there's two ways people go with it some
sometimes they go with like oh I'm gonna
be able to do that one day and give
people a bunch of about whatever
and some people go okay I'm never gonna
act like that yeah and then how and and
so you were Jim Webb's roommate plebe
summer just for a few days but we were
in the same company for all four years
yeah and then he's a heck of a guy yeah
no it was awesome it was a real honor to
have him on here and you know he he told
a similar story and he wrote about in
his in some of his books which was you
know a guy just smacking him in the ass
with some kind of bat it was our song
book and and they're telling him he
needs to say you know just admit that it
hurts and he wouldn't admit it
but same thing you know he's like if he
what did he say he said you know I don't
hold anything against those guys that
did that to me
but I remember there
name so yeah I think they made the list
for Jim Webb and then how did you end up
pick it so you you already automatically
knew you wanted to be a pilot yeah
absolutely and was that hard to get
selected for that no it was a service
selection is done based on class rank
and I graduated in the top 10% over the
bottom third of my class and that was
sufficient to get me and in aviation
since I couldn't fly this bad I really
wanted to go jets sorry guys I have to
admit that that due to due to my size
and my anthropometric measurements if I
had to punch out I would have left my
knees on the glare shield of the the
trainers how tall are you
that's six four yeah big this was you
know clearly and Jim Webb talked about
this when he was on the podcast you know
he's he was the guy in charge of hanging
up the names of the guys that had been
killed and and yet when I had Charlie
plum on who graduated I think in 64 or
he showed up in 64 no graduated 64
Vietnam wasn't even on the on the radar
that's for them and for you guys it you
know 1967 1968 it had to you you know
you had to have known okay I'm going to
fight in Vietnam when you walk into
mother B Bancroft Hall you go into the
rotunda which is a very larger open area
and when we started losing our former
classmates the graduates I'm sure Jim
explained but they put a poster board up
there with the picture out of the lucky
bag and a brief bio and not a
description but where they died and
initially it was just onesies twosies
but pretty soon that the March went all
the way around the rotunda and they had
to move it up into Memorial Hall and it
really brought home the fact that this
is this is serious this is a you know if
you're making up your minds whether or
not you wanted dedicate your lives
that in the defense of this country and
it might come at a considerable cost and
for 44 of our brothers it certainly did
44 Seawolves didn't make it back and I'm
sort of an emotional guy that one of the
few times that I've really cried openly
and then ashamedly was at the wall seen
seen a couple of my Gunners up there
just really brought it home to me
amazing people Gunners are so so that's
that's what you know you're getting into
upon commissioning and so you you get
commissioned and you graduated in 68
your class of 68 right and you then you
go to Pensacola Florida is that where
you go to flight school that's right
and that's that what you talked us a
little bit through the flight school
path you show up you learn to fly what a
t-38 is that no we you start out at t-34
okay and it's there's there's been a
change in the way they instruct naval
aviators now when we were going through
you had to do the flight the fixed-wing
flight syllabus first before you could
get into helicopters and then you go
through the helicopter syllabus and then
after that those of us that got orders
to Vietnam would go up to a Fort Rucker
and the army would instruct us in
tactics in armaments systems they did
they did a good job in prepping us and
then sent us overseas and the rest of it
would be done in country so the the the
training that we've received along the
way was was excellent that a lot of it
was just like back at the academy they
told us that hey guys the education you
receive here at the United States Naval
Academy cost the taxpayer approximately
two hundred and fifty thousand dollar
which is a lot of money back then and
our reply was yeah but yes sticking of
our butts a nickel at a time so you know
you know had you so now you're in the
pipeline for four helicopters had you
heard of sea Wolf's at this time were
you hearing about it did you is it
something that you said oh I want to go
do that we were just starting to hear
about it and you know it wasn't fully
developed in my mind it that's where I
wanted to go that it quickly became
there is a purpose for every element in
the military from the guys who swabs the
decks all the way on up but I didn't
want to be a bus driver I didn't want to
be a guy who bored holes in the sky so
this being a Seawolf
immediately appealed to me as an
opportunity to be able to I don't know
to pay back it's it's a funny thing and
I'll jump ahead a little here but I have
a cousin who is very close to me she's
like a sister to me
and I'd never really thought about
questions like you just ask that after
immediately after I got back from
Vietnam she was driving me on out to
family home in Walnut Creek California
and without taking her eyes off the road
she said how can you do it
and I thought about that for just a
minute and said well it was pretty easy
I went over there to bring as many of
our guys home safely as I could and in
some ways I failed in some ways I
succeeded but that's it I was enough of
a student to to understand that the
domino effect certainly that that wasn't
in my thinking you know your thinking
sort of 10 yards 10 yards but in the air
it's a little more expansive it's it's
the guys that you're flying with the
guys in your flight fireteam the guys on
your debt the guys who were
maintainer is back in been tui they're
the they're the guys you think about and
that's why you do it it okay so did you
get to select you get done with thumb
you get done with the training did you
get to select hey I want to go to the
squadron in Vietnam pretty much yes
was there a long list for that ten words
there I'm sorry they were more
volunteers than then got exiled I don't
know the mechanics of that I asked for
it I got it
and how did that look like showing up in
in Vietnam I was the only officer
assigned to the Seawolves who took that
reverse freedom flight on into Saigon
and I got there and they shuffled me off
to the Annapolis hotel which I thought
was a little unusual but you know I had
a couple of days to kill because there
wasn't any transfer transport down to a
tube into E and I knew a dear friend of
mine who was it in depth to at nabe and
he'd got over there before I did so I
figured nabe that's not too far away I'm
gonna go visit him and the next morning
I check out a 45 put it in my gym bag
I'm in civvies they didn't like us
roaming around town in onesies in the
uniform so I jumped on a navy bus out to
nabe know there's having a great time
talking to the guys at the Det there and
learn a little about what's going on and
comes time to leave and it's probably
about 16 30 and I say well I better get
back and they say well you just missed
the last bus but don't worry about it
you can take a pedicab so here I am
brand new in country I've got the zipper
in my on my gym bag open with my hand
very close to it and this Vietnamese
fellow is pedaling away taking me back
to the the hotel it took us about an
hour to get back there and I tipped him
generously because I'm not a light
fellow I was a lot lighter then but you
know Here I am my first day in country
and I'm gonna get grease tea
so yeah it's a tell us if you wouldn't
mind some of the about the formation the
Seawolves because it's a very cool story
about the mekong delta about the way
things the way the enemy moved through
the mekong delta and through the wrong
special zone and there was no roads and
the only way to get around those water
if you want to maybe expand on that just
so people can kind of get a feel for for
what started this whole thing off sure
sure
yeah the mekong delta is fed by water
from the himalayas it comes on down and
spreads out into a broad quasi oceanic
area basically it's mud and crap and
brown water and hence the brown water
Navy but at any rate yeah
the there are very few roads that do
anything but connect major cities in the
Mekong back family and consequently just
about all the traffic's moved by a
sampan or are junk and that's the way
people got around the infiltration that
the NVA and the the VC practice came
largely either on foot by bicycle or by
boat in order to counteract that task
force so one one six was put into place
game warden was the the operational
mission and we were there to interdict
that traffic and personnel ammunition
and food logistics that was moving down
into the Delta the army had took that
mission on first actually flying off a
couple of LCDs that were rigged with a
this makes you fly tech but that didn't
work out too well and not this is not
saying anything against the army but in
their syllabus they weren't trained on
instruments in Navy we were rigorous
first in fixed-wing and then in
helicopters so we were used to flying in
the and the Navy and and the army
was not and and that's that's because
the Navy has to fly at sea and land on
her on boat on ships that's right that's
it different missions at the time the
army outgrew that that it was it was
painful they had it at a different
mission than we did so they they had a
unit that was assigned to our OPCON and
they would fly a cover for for the small
boats now that was primarily the PBRs
and the Swift boats we didn't see many
Swift boats up had been luck we were
working with the PAPR sailors PBR patrol
boat river is a 32 foot fiberglass
luxury boat that was stripped clean and
I was highly manoeuvrable but it was I
say stripped clean of everything that
was non-essential they were very
lightweight had a little armor at all
that they were very heavily armed and
these boats if you talk about guys with
brass balls
they'd poke up into these impossibly
narrow canals and up Little River let's
just looking for trouble and it
frequently came their way so the army
was uh attempting to work with them
there were all sorts of a minor
operational problems to overcome
who's calling out the missions uh what
the support area is it just wasn't
working well so the Navy decided that we
needed a navy squadron and they've
turned hc1 the fleet angels but put a
few debts in place to help provide cover
for the the brown water Navy and by
brown water Navy I mean the small boat
guys the seals
any Navy Navy vessel that was down in
the in the Mekong
and it wasn't working well with the the
army hc1 picked it up it started working
very well because they understood the
Navy's mission much better than the army
and they were equipped with the
capabilities to fly both at night and in
bad weather and I don't know if you've
been in monsoon before but it's shitty
flood really bad so as you've already
mentioned on April Fool's Day in 67 they
decided that they in-country squadron
was required and that responsibility was
shifted from hc1 to Hal 3 we grew to
having nine detachments that were
scattered throughout the Delta to give
us a quick reaction time to virtually
any any area in the Mekong and each
detachment had two aircraft designed it
had two full crews for each aircraft and
that was about it but let me let me give
you a little info on the noble uh-1
Bravo I love that aircraft it was a
piece of crap it really was but it got
us out of out of a lot of trouble every
time we flew it and just for people that
are listen that's the classic vietnam
huey aircraft that's that's what you see
that's what you see in movies that
that's it yeah there really was sort of
a McHale's Navy that okay catch hey that
was attached to the Seawolves
the the army was just getting rid of
their Bravo models to go to this two of
their Charlie's which had several
hundred greater horsepower a more
maneuverable at Bob Loblaw and they had
some old Bravo's sitting around and
rather than shipping him back to the
boneyard or destroying them in place
they gave him to the Navy so frequently
we had a lot of rebuilding to do before
we turned these guys loose but God bless
the army they gave us a they gave us our
aircraft support for the Bravo and the
Navy chain was not the best so you've
it's easy to say beg borrow or steal
borrow or steal is what we did quite
well quite well our guys were incredible
we a chief had grabbed a couple of guys
and go out and come back with exactly
what we needed and you don't ask a
question about that you just put it into
play so the the nine debts two
helicopters in each each Huey was
basically configured with two seven shot
rocket pods 2.75 folding thin aerial
rockets we had a pair of 60s that were
mounted with a flex gun they a co-pilot
control those but the the thing that
really made us a unique and powerful was
our door Gunners when I first got there
and just just for a very short period of
time our door Gunners were still firing
60s from the shoulder and that was just
an incredibly powerful tool in keeping
the bad guys heads down during our break
and prepping the area for the next
aircraft to uh to roll in so we
typically have a door gunner on one side
and on the other side if we were lucky
of 50 eventually this grew we got some
mini guns most all of our debt birds
eventually had mini guns and the guys in
the back would fly them and it did
wonders for keeping uh keeping heads
down I was did the 50 cals
that we had when we went from shoulder
hair held 60s to there's a lesson there
our guys would it wasn't unusual to see
them standing out on the skids firing
cover for us that was a great good thing
but it also
resulted in brass in the sink elevator
and the or it just wasn't really freely
acceptable if you brass a tail rotor
he'll know about it it's a rough ride
going back in but and they decided that
no he can't have that and sort of tied
the Gunners hands by putting what they
called a pole in the in the door
and mounted that the sixty to it
well the guys got more than a little
inventive and decided that if one 60s
good two would be better and mounted to
one yeah here here we go again
Hayden thanks yeah but mounted to 60s
there and found out that they were brass
in the tail rotor still so what they did
was they rotated each 90 degrees in
opposing directions and all of a sudden
the brass Ian was no longer much of a
problem did essentially the same with
our 50s they mounted that so that it
would fire 90 degrees longitudinally and
that was a very powerful weapon for not
only keeping keeping guys down but also
gave us a great degree of flexibility in
the in the break and perhaps I should
explain that by the break we typically
would fly in a in a wagon wheel type
type of approach to helicopters roughly
flying 180 out from one another so one
is it rolling in on the target as the
other is coming around behind it so when
you then break off the target the next
helicopter is in there laying down its
fire and that that 50 would would really
help us out in both identifying problem
areas and taking care of the problem
yeah that's a great a great background
and and you know even when you watch
scramble the sea Wolf's the just and all
the footage is just unbelievable footage
of the way you guys were flying and what
the Gunners were doing Gunners hanging
out and shooting underneath the bird
back in the other direction yeah hanging
out by a Gunners belt they might have
invented the term Gunners belt there I
was go ahead
there's a right of passage that most of
the FN jeez got and when I was in that
FN g seat I learned it one dark and
stormy night we're flying along India
and they they hack the aircraft
commander diverted my attention off to
the left and I turned back right here in
the window of the Huey was one of my
gutters who is Mooney this is gonna be
fun that and the other was if you were
new to the depth as a pilot and you're
gonna get a colorful a brass and it was
really easy for them to do when they had
the free guns they got a little more in
the found of later on that that's that's
freaking dangerous smart so speaking of
fun one of the one of the things I
pulled off of the website Seawolf dot
org is you guys had this thing that you
called the wolf gram which was sort of
sort of like a sitrep for all the all
the different elements that were out
there and I think it paints a pretty
good picture of the overall attitude and
I pulled out one of the clips and I'm
just gonna read it so this is your debt
debt for from beautiful downtown Bend
luck the Fogg cutters of debt for would
like to wish everyone a merry monsoon
season only ten shopping days left we'd
better start with lieutenant JG who
white before we forget him everyone else
has
he uh he though he was leaving in May
but view pers forgot to assign him a new
duty station admin forgot to request a
flight booking for him and operations
forgot to inform him that this that his
FTL papers had been signed but we're
sure we'll finally for that we're but
we're sure things will finally turn
around for what's-his-name
lieutenant Deacon John Johnson left on
R&R to Hawaii and lieutenant JG rookie
rich can't read the name farmer farmer
yeah farmer was called in to straighten
out bin toy been to e cutting us to
three FTL's and an axe commander Hammond
will still have to fly every day even
after the Deacon gets back beaucoup map
as lieutenant Johnson is referred to by
mamasan won't be much good for anything
after coming back from Hawaii rookie
riches talent for hiding should be of
great value in Bend to e lieutenant JG
check Carlos Steele has opened a chain
of combination taco stand slash minigun
exchange outlets with branches in
coochie tan tan an and been luck with
others soon to be opening in long Binh
ving long and Viet Tian
lieutenant JG weird Harold black is
still looking for his mysteriously
vanishing n60 bolts latest debt for
basketball casualty was lieutenant JG
buckets coffee named after his golden
touch on the court who got four stitches
in his head after going for a rebound
who will it be in April three additions
arrived this past month
lieutenant tom rebola and lieutenant JG
Denny rally which is you sir are new in
country and lieutenant JG bill belts was
shafted shifted from dead eight oh well
with TV booze and all the attractions of
the big city what more could you want
as one of our departed pilots used to
say going home is for sissies
so and you guys these are all alive
they're fantastic to read I read that
too my buddy Dave Burke where I sent I
sent him a copy of it and he said that's
the best sitrep I've ever read in my
life so you guys had you know it's it's
good cuz you know I always talking and
and every vet that comes on here we kind
of talk about how we have fun and that
shows that and I guess getting mooned
through your side window also shows that
you guys were having fun I don't know if
the hot brass is fun but you guys were
having a great time and you guys were
making it fun and at the same time man
it was very intense and very dangerous
one of the things that you know you you
you kind of threw it out there you said
hey we put these debts all over the
place so we could have a quick response
time and what that meant was you guys
were spread out in these debts so that
you could get to guys on the ground
within a matter of minutes tell me about
that op tempo and what it was like when
when they scrambled the Seawolves
well we had two full crews for each one
of our two birds and what that meant was
you were 12 hours on 12 hours off 365 24
whatever in order to support the the
brown water Navy when they got in the
ship they they needed us right away and
we could literally get off the deck
in about three minutes and that put us
out there quickly enough that we could
probably get them out of trouble the
worst thing that could could happen to
them in my estimation other than losing
someone as is losing their engine
because then they were just out there
with they were a grape
know it no place to go so all they could
do is just absorb the the incoming and
with that in mind what we would do is go
on out and try and first get their heads
down and then to start working the
target
we had a very close relationship with
the the PBR sailors very close
those guys were sticking their necks out
every day and that the times they got in
trouble we were happy to go and and try
and extricate them on no matter up no
matter what but one of the great quotes
that I saw in the in the history that I
was reviewing is the first contact that
hc1 made they they the two boats had
gone out on patrol and it stumbled
across a battalion size element with
about 80 Sam pans and that junks that
we're trying to cross a river and the
boats came under obviously intense fire
when the sea wolves got there a couple
of minutes after this the the incoming
fire team League contacts the chief of
the boat and says where do you want us
to put in our strike and he said
something like hell I want you boys to
go in there and hold field day on those
guys and that's sort of the attitude
that they're you know it is it's it's an
overused term but it's a brotherhood it
truly is you did we do anything for
those guys they were putting it all out
did you guys did you guys um pre-brief
with them for missions or how did you
figure that out on how did you figure it
out so did you know where they were
going did you know what their target was
did they pre briefed you unfortunately
we had intelligence that was to put it
kindly generally a piece of crap it
wasn't very good for a number of reasons
for a number of reasons but what we do
is we'd talk to the guys on the boats we
know what the tactical situation was in
the Noa and we would know where they
were going and what what they were doing
that is are you going out for a bunker
are you doing an insert with seals we
get that information
the from the team that was there
actually we didn't have a team it was uh
just as a squad yeah but we'd share the
answer the information so we've know
about where they were going and what we
do as soon as we got airborne is head
for the the pre-brief spot and they've
got update the info in route so that by
the time we got there we knew that where
the fire was coming from what the
situation was with the boats and where
we were likely to put in our first
strike
so the deconfliction as far as where you
were shooting and friendly fire and all
that was I mean as long as as long as
they tell you hey north north side of
the river or something like that is that
how you would deconflict and did you
when you were supporting ground troops
how the hell did you know who was who
down there
we'd by heaven pop smoke and that
generally worked but the the worst thing
that could happen is when you say pop
red and one shows up right where you
expect it and one shows up a hundred
meters on down yeah so the bad guys had
our head our freaks and that well I
don't know if they had her freaks or not
but they could certainly see a smoke and
they'd pop it also right same one and
that could create a little confusion but
it also gave us a locus of points that
we could talk to the guys on the boats
and they could direct our fire and one
thing that's important about that the
2.75 folding family aerial rocket was a
great tool I didn't like it much because
it wasn't all that uncommon to have one
of the the fins not open properly and
then it had just go squirrelly and go
anywhere if you had the aircraft
trimmed up it could be an effective
weapon but I didn't like to use it too
far out because that gave it more of an
opportunity to develop a mind of its own
I use it more as a as a close-in weapon
so these the you'd be sitting in your in
your hooch or whatever and you'd be
stamped you know just standing by if it
was your 12-hour shift and then all of a
sudden the radio call would come in they
they tell you guys go what was the
procedure like from their and
elbows out to the aircraft the one of
the other crews first first guy there
would be suddenly uh the aircraft was
pre cocked but they'd go ahead and set
the the rockets up for us and jump in
hit the button and go you uh every I
think that it's safe to say that
practically every operational mission
that we flew we took off over max gross
weight you'd pull it up enough to get it
out of the revetment and get it out
there and what we do when we were really
seriously overweight it just sort of
incident I head and get a little forward
momentum on the helicopter and then drop
the collective which puts all the weight
down on the skids and spread the skids
and then pop it up a little and the
aircraft would beasts would slingshot up
to all about three feet and then you
know yeah hopefully you'll get across
the v40 fence at the end of the end of
the runway it was colorful but had to do
it in order to carry enough ordnance to
uh get guys out of trouble and then I
mean um when we were in Iraq we always
felt like the helicopters which win
Ramadi the helicopters they wouldn't
really fly over the city of Ramadi
because it was there was too dangerous
for them a couple times that they came
in it was like it was like a just
massive machine gun fire at them and
they didn't really enjoy that too much
but you guys were just so so my point is
that helicopters and actually vehicles
as well they're like a bullet
magnets right everywhere you see a
helicopter coming the enemy just sees
that and focuses on it
you guys must have it you had to be
taking fire all the time yep all the
time you get used to it yeah one of my
Gunners reminded me of a the first time
that we saw a 51 Cal coming at us it was
a was night and these things you know
they it's a big as a basketball yes as
big as a freakin basketball coming up at
you we started to see the Frazier's come
up at it and he says damn you did the
right thing
I said yeah and he see Lord the
collective immediately got down on the
deck and then came around the weakest
could adjust but those things are
frightening oh yeah that's clutch it's
it goes with the turf you're 20 years
old that was 23 at the time and it's you
think the mission you think the the
pride that you taken in the guys and the
pride they take in you and it's
frightening
you know there's I was terrified at
times I think we all were that you get
by that you get by that you think about
the guys down there who were really in
the ship and it's easy to apply what you
know tactically and get the job done
that's that's another thing that that's
why I was kind of asking you about
meeting with the guys on the ground
because you guys are doing this and and
I'm sure in some situations you would
never met the people that were down
there and you're still risking your
lives to go in there and give them the
support that they need yeah it's what we
did there's that there's a
counterintuitive thing to two
helicopters that you just mentioned
which is so when you're getting shot at
from the ground if you get lower it
takes away some of their field of fire
right brightly so so you would think oh
there's someone shooting at me I'm gonna
get up and go away when the reality is
if you get lower you know that that
person there's gonna be trees or
whatever terrain features in between
that's gonna take a little bit time to
uh to get your instincts go into that
direction
yeah it certainly does but it's amazing
how quick those instincts are developing
when you got somebody shooting at you
and then the maintenance crews the birds
archivist I saw pictures of birds they
were just like it looked like they had
been used for target practice yeah
coming back you go watch that movie
scramble to see what it looks like
target practice was used that's what
they were using the boards for target
practice that's what some of them look
like and the maintenance crews were just
they they said they were making patches
from beer cans that's true that's true
and the guys were proud of that and the
the patch that was a beer can would not
be painted over generally ya know and
there's one thing that I want to say and
this is gonna sound like a one-trick
pony and my love for the gunners but
those guys not only fired the weapons
they serviced the weapons they serviced
the the helicopters they performed all
the dailies they were all qualified
plane captains they kept that thing up
and running for us so that we could walk
out with our silk scarves and that strap
the thing on and take him out to where
they needed to be in order to get the
job done no we're not Air Force we don't
believe in silk scarf sorry Air Force
brethren and then so you're doing this
this is a crazy op tempo operational
tempo of 12 on 12 off 365 days that's
insane you get used to it you know it's
funny have you got you got eight hours
of sleep okay and then you got four
hours to eat and then the other 12 hours
you're on standby to go fly into into
gun battles I got 365 days yeah I got
nervous though when I wasn't flying you
know a decent aviator wants to fly and
it's hard sometimes this around waiting
for your turn we played and lifted a lot
of weight played a lot of volleyball
played volleyball with and against the
the seals and sometimes the
boat drivers it just it was fifty metres
from the from the aircraft and that kept
this kept us right there so we could
respond quickly and then um how often
were you guys do in casualty evacuation
only one needed yeah it wasn't a primary
mission of ours if somebody got shot up
and needed to lift out of town we
provide that and occasionally we'd get a
call that someone was wounded and we'd
go out and pick him up but generally
that was a job that was done by some
certifiable idiots that I love the the
dust off pilots you got that 20 19 20
year old kids that are out there given
the keys to do a a maserati course this
was only a Huey but still you get the
idea they were crazy they'd fly into
into anything my hat really goes off to
him because they'd fly into areas where
they shouldn't that's another thing I
talked about with Colonel bill reader
who was on this podcast and same thing I
mean he just said that the the pilots
back then and maybe it's because the
aircraft were very inexpensive compared
to the you know to what they fly
nowadays they don't want to risk the
aircraft now but he said these guys they
were just flying into like it was a your
your aircraft is just gonna get hit
that's the way it's gonna be yeah
deal with it and if you ever get to get
the opportunity to read the some of the
citation for their Congressional Medal
for the these are helo pilots it's it's
incredible what they did now what I was
and always on this show give the same
praise that you give to the machine
gunners because the machine gunners in
in a ground combat it's the machine
gunners that are going to allow you to
be able to maneuver and get away from a
situation or maneuver towards you know
they're gonna allow you to move and same
thing with with your Gunners and what
they were doing so you had a gunner on
each side that's right that would
protect the flanks that's right
one of them on either a 60 or a dual 60
and the other one on a 50 Cal generally
or eventually a minigun oh and then you
guys got too many guns
yes I will in I looked at there was a
real real fast flash on the screen in
scramble to see Wolfe's there's a
minigun and it's actually it's upside
down you can't I had to pause it to read
it it said the Lord giveth and the
minigun taketh away yeah it was a
formidable weapon for a close close air
support yeah for people that don't know
what a minigun is it fires it fires what
five thousand rounds a minute I mean
it's absolutely ridiculous what it's yes
I don't know what the rate is but it's
it gets your attention yeah and it just
it's powered it's it's powered it's
electrically powered so it actually
feeds the ammunition faster than than a
normal mechanical weapon could fire but
it just it's crazy how much and how much
how many rounds because I think it's
5,000 something like that it's a
ridiculous yeah and then you guys got
those so those were on your birds while
you were on deployment that's right yeah
as far as the the minigun goes you know
it doesn't go bang bang bang it goes at
the rate of fire is phenomenal in the
the Gunners loved it but you know
there's a little John Wayne in all of us
and I think every one of them would like
to go back to the yeah
did the free guns one thing that I do
want to point out is that we were not
very well equipped so when we were up
and around you know on patrol or
actually out there engaged in had to fly
into a gas up and and rearm we'd go into
an army base because the army had all
the fuel and they had nails the 2.75
makes a boom but if you can load it with
flechettes you can really keep the enemy
down so we'd go on up there
depending on the tactical situation
if we had a cause they're anti-personnel
some something developing on the ground
we'd uh we'd load up there and that's
where I saw my first Cobra the snake was
an impressive aircraft it was so much it
had so much more firepower than any one
of our Huey's but where do you put the
Gunners you know it's for an FC team
they don't have any suppression for
rolling off target
other than your wingman and it did you
know it was intriguing but it just
didn't make sense to me yeah I remember
this correctly that at one point you're
whoever the commander was at the time
got offered hey do you guys want some
cobras and the answer was no we need to
stick with the Huey's I'd heard that
story I don't don't know whether it's
true or not oh yeah yeah yeah we like
that but uh you know one of the guys you
mentioned in the wolf Graham and I will
mention his name Chuck steely up Chuck
was quite a guy and he would go out on
to requisition parts for us at the time
the army had a contractor tie an
electron that was doing the work on
their aircraft and you know they're
bored out of their skull when they don't
have anything to work on so they got a
loach and started rebuilding it from
spare parts from here and there and got
it to be fully functional and you know
to have an observation helicopter like
that to go out and snoop and poop with
us that would be incredible
Chuck engineered a deal where for a
refrigerator full of beer they'd give us
this aircraft you know it was written
off the rolls they're closing it but you
know they said hey if you have a problem
let us know we'll come down take care of
it I like to think that chuck was
unplugging our refrigerator when the
deado and see him and not just know but
L know that sort of thing was not
unusual over there
god bless Chuck he did did everybody a
lot of great service the the speaking of
beer apparently the the wolf on the Sea
Wolf insignia somehow based on the
Lowenbrau beer can that's what they saw
allegedly that's what they said I can
neither confirm nor deny
you know strangely enough I didn't drink
much beer at all and I was over there
because they they seem to treat it with
something that just put the taste-off we
all thought it was formaldehyde that was
the the going rumour but when they told
us that in cool when I was in Guam my
first deployment they told us the same
thing yeah that there was from aldehyde
that rumors been heard that rumor
survived from 1969 to 1992 and I was on
my first deployment there was
formaldehyde in the beer but how did the
beer taste awful and I kept trying to
see if I could make it taste better but
I did not succeed
there's so some of the stuff that you're
talking about you know from a leadership
perspective
you got you got guys that are risking
their lives every time that call comes
how how did you did you see guys that
that got to a point where they couldn't
take it anymore did you did you have
situations where you had to send guys
back to the rear what did you do when
you saw a guy kind of started to start
to get too nervous to go
this may sound self-serving and I don't
care I didn't see anyone in our debts
and I did not see directly anyone who
behaved in a cowardly manner an
overcautious manner we didn't have
anyone that was sent back to the to the
rear there was
a camaraderie that you just can't
explain to somebody who hasn't enjoyed
it it's a it's an honor to serve with
people like that and we all took pride
in our reputations among our squadron
mates so it it wasn't hard at all and
and that was so clear when you watch
scramble the sea Wolf's it's so clear
and there's this incredible that you can
see the camaraderie and you can hear it
when you read through the the the
wolfgramm so you can see that guys are
having a good time and there's this I
mean what I would consider and you can
tell me if I'm wrong but like a peer
pressure of hey we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna do this you know I've often
said that when you get to a good seal
platoon it's not a team it's not a
platoon it's like a gang that you have
mix again and we just don't allow for
that bad attitude to creep out yeah yeah
I feel the same way about the BSE wolves
and this might be a good time to share
with you the fact that I at one time
after returning from Vietnam was so fed
up with the mission that we were flying
it was an aging aircraft it didn't have
systems that were required to do the job
that the job itself was not that
important and you know you come from
living on a drum dren alone for a year
and then come back and you're expected
to I don't know figuratively put your
boots up on the table one day I got so
pissed off the middle of the morning I
jumped in my Corvette remember that hey
I learned I learned jumped in my
Corvette and tore on up to Coronado and
two of the seals that we operated with
friends were there and I walked into the
office they had their LSDs pulled up
face-to-face
and I said guys I've had it I want to
join up and they looked at each other
and they locked up their secret and each
of them grabbed me by an elbow and took
me up to the little Club in Coronado and
we serve poundin beers that tasted great
no formaldehyde there and by the middle
of the afternoon they'd convinced me
that being a peacetime seal wasn't
everything that uh that I would expect
and that they the Navy had put an awful
lot of investment into making me what I
was and I could make them far better
contribution by continuing to fly and I
I turned my back on my opportunity to
find out whether I had what it takes to
become a seal I'm surprised that those
guys well I'm surprised they didn't talk
you into it those must have been they
must I was Rhys once they got enough
beer in him they did they didn't have
you down at down at Budds with a law go
to stand over your head is there any
particular missions in when you were in
Vietnam that that stand out as you know
one of the ones on scrambles he will set
they talked about this was absolutely
ridiculous they're talking about the the
the helicopter was the helicopters were
there supporting a unit on the ground
there was no one to relieve them they
needed more fuel they were running out
of fuel the fuel lights on there's still
no one - no one to relieve the
helicopters and provide support they say
you know what screw it we're just gonna
stay until we run out of gas
and that's and that's what they did they
stayed until they ran out of gas the
other group came in they used ammo cans
to refuel to carry once - once the fire
on the ground had subsided they used
ammo cans to refuel the the helicopters
that were out of fuel so they could get
back to base that's freaking crazy well
you know we never really took time to
think about whether it was crazy or not
you got a job to do and you know that
that's probably a natural way to explain
it that was the job he went out and did
that because that's what was expected
that's what the guys on me in the boats
expected of you that's what the SEAL
team that we had these are the seals
that we had operator benlloch expected
and when they call you you go that's
another thing I think is really
impressive about the sea Wolf's 'as well
first of all they took volunteers to go
do the job and like you said a bunch of
people volunteered but the other thing
is and and I heard some of the vets
talking about this some of the sea wolf
vets talking about the fact that they'd
say oh I was in the Navy and I was you
know in the ship in Vietnam people say I
you were in the Navy anyone in the
but the reality is people you wouldn't I
can't imagine that there was any of the
Gunners that when they join the Navy
they thought to themselves what I'm
gonna be is a door gunner and direct
combat with the enemy these are guys
that were joined the Navy for whatever
reason and they end up in that job where
the you know they're doing this day in
day out and risking their life day-in
day-out not not really what they signed
up for and yet they held the line over
and over and over again all of them
volunteers yeah yeah it's it Amane it
humbles me to have been able to operate
with guys like that and you know I did
the pilots yeah the pilots of brass
balls it was expected it was the job the
Gunners had those balls and then some
because they kept us up kept the
aircraft up kept the systems up I had a
leadership lesson when I first got there
that grown up my dad you know he we'd
hunt and fish and I had fired our we had
two 14s for each bird they hung on the
back of the yeah pilot seat and I'd
taken one on out we had a little
makeshift range and fired it and brought
it back on in after I was done
and took it in to the crew area to clean
it you would have thought that I had
just stepped on a baby rabbit I mean it
was Maura it was flight it was
respectful but give me that thing yeah
and the guys had that feeling about the
armament you know if this is my job if I
do this so you know it took a little
getting used to it was easier to let him
clean my 45 then I just kind of want to
but you know when you're when you're
there you you start to get to know these
guys really well and I I don't you
didn't loot you didn't have anyone
killed from your debt while you were
there is that correct that's correct but
obviously other guys in other deaths
were killed while you were there did you
guys have any kind of and this is
something I've talked about before as
Americans and I think it's just because
we have so many different cultures here
we don't have a good protocol to deal
with to deal with death and you know
other other cultures around the world if
someone dies you know you you do this
for a day you do this for a day you say
this prayer you you go through the
ceremony and then you move on and
Americans we have so many different
cultures here that are all mixed
together and death isn't something that
happens all the time so we really don't
know a lot of times hey what am I
supposed to do and I think that's what
that's what causes people problems is
they don't know they don't know how to
handle they don't know how to put
closure on it and so it just kind of
sticks around when you guys would learn
that that someone in your debt had been
killed
was there any protocol that you guys set
up was there anything that you guys did
to to try and take that on board and
then move past it I probably miss out on
a leadership opportunity in when guys
got killed and other deaths in combat or
even just fairing and aircraft in for
maintenance I didn't sit down with the
guys and talk about it
i internalize it and being Irish would
reflect on all the good times we had
didn't think about what what went wrong
didn't want to know initially you know
eventually you do because it's important
for for your trade that I just think
about the good times that we we shared
together I lost a couple of Academy
classmates I lost some great friends
that I made while I was in country one
young fella and I don't wanna mention
any names
but he and I were both bicyclists and
the one thing that he wanted to do when
he got back home was built himself the
Primo bike and to start to start
competing and they never got that
opportunity
and when you when you personalize
something like that when you think about
the opportunities that are lost in a
heartbeat it makes you very thankful to
be alive and makes you very thankful of
to have known that person and it makes
you feel like you should redouble your
efforts to get the sons of that
that took that life away from him if you
can help focus your aggression and
that's a good thing
yeah no doubt about it and that was um I
guess my way again
I was uneducated no one ever taught me
but one thing I did is okay we're gonna
go to work yeah that's the thing that I
knew how to do that's what I still know
how to do is like go to work and you
know there's I guess you could say
there's some you know eventually you got
out you got to deal with it you got to
feel it more in the future but man when
I was overseas it's like yeah okay we're
gonna work and and that's where the
focus becomes because you know and also
from my perspective was like you know
your guys that's what they would want
you to do that's what they would want
you to do so let me let me share
something with you based upon what your
guys would want you to do
came home from a mission one night we
were in contact and you know it you're
you're decompressing and I walk up to my
rack and there's this manila envelope
for lieutenant JG Raleigh's eyes only
and I feel Ono somebody back on back
home has died and I open this thing up
with trembling hands and pull it out and
it's a standard Navy message and I said
hi honey I'm gonna be an Tanzanian three
days time come on up in there and see me
Sean's mom though the love of my life
callsign stinky doesn't have anything to
do with personal problems it's a matter
of attitude yeah she was a flight
attendant for Braniff and she was flying
freedom birds in and out and she had one
coming in Ben Lux only about 40 klicks
south of Saigon and okay and you know
word immediately spread like wildfire
throughout the debt and my guy god bless
him they slept in a sandbag bunker or
enlisted crew and it was normally pretty
ripe but it was also the only place that
was really it had a little bit of
privacy
well they had determined that I was
going to bring stinky on down for lunch
I pick her up in town sonoda bring her
on down so they had that place spit shot
they did it but it was alright it turned
out to be a bit of a disappointment we
flew up flew a helicopter on up to town
salute and you know we're going over a
bad guy country so it was armed and I
land the thing in front of I had no I
didn't land it I wasn't flying it but we
land in front of the terminal there at
Anza Newton immediately this Air Force
truck comes on out with its cherry job
going and this this sergeant says you
can't land here and I put it out to him
that we already had and that we're just
waiting for the arrival and
we solved the problem by saying listen
this aircraft is armed why don't you
stay here and watch it for us and we'll
just be a little while so we walked on
over this big old green Braniff jet
comes on in and everybody gets off and
you know the incoming guys aren't nearly
as gay and festive as yeah outgoing guys
so they get off and there's Gail
standing up at the top of the ladder
just waving at me so turns out she can't
get off the aircraft but they didn't say
anything about us getting on so you know
Mike goes on up the the ladder and we're
in there and Gail's introducing them to
the other stewardesses and they're
loving it
and we go to the back of the aircraft
and sat there for 45 minutes just
talking with each other but when we got
back and Gail wasn't there the the guys
were just crestfallen they were so
excited about having somebody there and
you know they III don't think the place
was ever cleaned again but that was my
experience at dating my hometown honey
in the zone what was it like was it
standard Vietnam we're just replacements
would come when it was time for a guy to
rotate out a new guy would show up
pretty much like I mentioned earlier I
was sort of kind of drift at the
Annapolis hotel and happened to run into
a got weird Harold who you referenced in
that wolfgramm he came just walking
through with the debt for O&C Colonel
Hammond we called him currently was a
navy commander and Dave introduced us
and said hey this is a great guy we
should have him and as it turns out they
had an opening and within a matter of a
few days I was in debt for so it it was
sort of a roll your own environment yeah
you know obviously they put guys ndu
into slots where they needed them but
that it was fluid
so then your times coming up to to head
home as it wasn't a one-year 365 days
yeah pretty much yes and then did you
I'm you you stayed right on doing your
12 on 12 off until it was time to go
what they did normally do is for the
last week or two that you were in
country send you into a band to e for
the for the out processing and we'd fly
with the sea Lords so you know you
didn't stop flying it was just a
different mission and then you get back
that then you then you get okay your
time's up and it's time to go home yeah
pretty much
well you know there there'd be a bit of
a party a drunk ex but but other than
that yeah yeah that's that was that was
it then how was that transition going
from Vietnam and then what how many how
many hours later you're back in America
or how many days it was a
straight-through shot we stopped off in
Honolulu there was one other stuff maybe
Guam and then Honolulu and then home it
straight through and and to wait your so
you what are you married you weren't
married yet no no we got engaged on R&R
and Hong Kong and that's a tuberous
story so you got R&R from Vietnam that
you're your bride-to-be in Hong Kong
that's right and proposed yeah
you know we'd already talked about it we
knew it was coming got down on a knee in
Jimmy's kitchen and all of a sudden it
but it was pretty interesting when I
arrived in Hong Kong we were booked a
room at the Hilton so I go on down there
and you know I'm checking in and I'm in
my uniform
so the manager happens to be walking
behind the desk and says ah mister lally
mrs. Lally is waiting for you in your
room tomorrow what's mom gonna think
well of course
Gayle had gotten in a day early times
were different back then
so your transition from from Vietnam
back to America all of a sudden and you
were you know people people use the term
wild west sometimes to describe various
military situations where it was how it
was like the Wild West
hmm I don't know if it gets much more
Wild West they see well for Vietnam it
just doesn't see the way you guys were
running things the way the support that
you got or didn't get the I mean just
the fact like you guys didn't even have
flight suits they did they wouldn't
issue him or something like that and you
guys were just wearing kind of what you
what what you could get a hold of
everything was sort of Wild West
it took longer to get into a flight suit
than it did to come on no Mac certain
certain bands and frequently it wasn't
Nomex and as they say you know I've
flown missions in my tiny runners just
that we leave our gear there in the seat
and if I was playing volleyball and if
they scrambled us you you don't think
about anything but getting in that
aircraft in getting it cranking so yeah
it was Wild West and God yeah and then
and then you get back to America and
you're still in the Navy right yeah
how was that well got through training
you know first of all you're just
decompressing that was newly married
Gailen or getting used to living
together she's dealing with my unique
personality it was sort of a scrapbook
we partied art it's so when we got back
a couple of seals one of them had a em
was connected to a family that owned one
of the mansions there in Coronado on the
on the waterfront I think that was first
Street Front Street at any rate just a
man it was a beat-up old place but it
was truly a mansion and they had a
couple mattresses on the floor and they
had a table in the kitchen but no
furniture and they had a a tapper and we
go over there and just party like crazy
and the where I'm going with this story
is
all of that time and through all the
craziness and through all of the
drinking there was only one person who
got hurt as a result of overindulging he
refer an his car into a telephone pole
didn't didn't kill him didn't even hurt
him very much but that was the only
instance that I know of and the only
casualty we had to alcohol was that same
guy who turned himself in to four AAA
and was cashiered out of the Navy and
then for ten years he was sober clean
and sober and he applied to get back in
and the Navy God loved it let him back
in but more remarkable than that this is
one of our pilots now from the Seawolves
they gave him his wings back and he
finished up his career flying that's
awesome but the point is we we had a
really great time when we got back and
all that was sort of a haze but when I
checked into the squadron after I
completed the rag learned to fly the the
nor noble h3 sea slug via our commanding
officer took me in and in my checker
board interview says I know where you've
been I know what you've done you aren't
gonna get away with any of that crap
here and that there was a leadership
lesson there I knew that I never wanted
to be like him if that had to be
intimidating for a guy though that's
taken on these these pilots that have
been doing what you had been doing and
all of a sudden they got to try and rein
these guys back into the world I hope
I'm not going into too many sea stories
but that great friend about the only guy
names I'm using guys who were deceased
but that huge canvas was a co-pilot and
we were sent off to four
to Guam for some specialized training
and he and I are there in our you know
poopie suits at the bar the O club bar
at the Air Force Base on Guam and we're
enjoying a couple of beers which tasted
good and all of a sudden they smell
rings like crazy and income these guys
in in pressed flight suits with ascots
and everybody in the bar all the Air
Force guys are standing at attention
this b-52 crew coming back from a
mission and we're just sitting there
with our elbows on the bar and the crowd
didn't know what to make of us but they
didn't get too close to us either come
on we all have a mission to you and
Rolling Thunder was very important if
taken to its conclusion we might not
have lost that war and I used the words
loss and war carefully there and that
that's not that a slip of the tongue if
they've got a mission to do but I mean
yeah the war from 40,000 feet they're
worried about Sam's because they turn in
at this I don't want to go there I'm
sorry I'd like to apologize to the
United States Air Force and all the
noble men and women who fly for the Air
Force yeah that's actually you know fo
some when we got back from Ramadi we we
got after it in a very similar way for
several months I don't know how long you
did but yeah there was a lot of beer and
other things that were drank and and I
don't know
you know there's it was sort of it was
sort of it seemed like the the normal
thing to do I don't know it seemed like
we were going to kind of get it out of
our systems for a little while and you
know get over it because it is is you
know it's not that big of a deal I don't
want to make it sound like it's all
crazy but you know you're over there and
it's like okay it's a little bit of it's
it's a different it's a different
scenario
and you got to kind of process through
the fact that everything that you just
doing whatever a week ago two weeks ago
three weeks ago is now completely
different but when your life is
completely different and there's no one
shooting at you and there's no one not
you're not gonna losing your guys which
was the the the weight that I felt
lifted off of me about a month after I
got home I was I didn't woke up one
morning and I just kind of felt
different and I kind of I was like why
do I feel I felt different in a good way
and what I felt was oh I was thinking
about why do I feel different right now
and as I sat there and thought about I
was like I'm not worried about any of my
guys getting killed right now which was
the first time in months that I hadn't
been thinking about that all day every
day and so yeah when you come home
there's there's definitely that and I I
think it's I think you got to pay
attention as a leader to everyone in
that group to make sure that guys are
staying within the box and staying
within what's what's and I guess
possibly normal for those situations
because you can definitely be you can
there will definitely be individuals
that they'll they'll they'll go to
fahren that they're not making the
transition and what they need is you
know some help someone to come alongside
pull alongside and say hey man let's
let's take it back a little bit or you
know let's let's readjust and you know
life's gonna be normal again and all
that unfortunately the the way we were
rolled in and out of the squadron when
we left and came back to a world it was
pretty much an individual effort so that
and I also tempered with the fact that
your war was entirely different than
ours I would imagine yours was more up
close and personal than than ours
tell you the truth I don't recall ever
reflecting on whether my guys were gonna
come back from this mission or not you
know it's something that we just all did
we all did it together
and I don't mean that to sound callous
it just just isn't wasn't part of my my
thinking and that goes back to what
cousin Kim asked you know how did you do
it yeah yeah trying to bring everybody
back home yeah I don't I definitely do
without question thought about that
every every day that was the biggest
thing that I thought about every day was
because there was guys getting killed
every day basically there was memorial
services every day there was you know
one of the one of the things that have
talking abouts a bunch but there was a
vehicle graveyard outside it wasn't it
was on the way to the gate to leave camp
Ramadi there was a vehicle graveyard
where all the vehicles that have been
blown up and destroyed by IEDs and there
was I would say 50 or 75 maybe even 100
but a massive area and so in order to
leave the gate you drove by that it was
it was a pretty harsh reminder and you
know my guys would go out on missions I
wasn't always going on missions because
I was overall in charge and there was
multiple units and so a lot of times I'd
be just saluting the guys as they'd be
leaving and and that's a worse feeling
of like okay you know you just you just
got your damn fingers crossed and you
hope you've done everything you can and
hope you've mitigated the risk but that
was the heaviest the heaviest weight for
me was just that daily fought every
because there was also there was the
fact that there was always guys in the
field almost always there was almost
always one of my you know little
detachments of guys was out there with
seven guys and 20 Iraqi soldiers and
there was gunfights going on and and
that's the way it was that was the that
was the heaviest thing from a leadership
perspective for me and yeah so when I
got home it took about a month you know
before I was like before any and the
other thing is I didn't well everything
that I'm saying about that feeling I was
barely conscious of it while I was there
I was like it was there but I was more
focused on doing the job I was more
focused on it kind of cooked me like you
know when they say the Frog we put the
frog in the boiling water you cook it
slow whatever you it was like that it
was more like that like over time it
just built up and what I did was just
focused on work and working hard but
then when I got home it was like I said
it was like a month after I got home I
woke up one day and just felt like
a a weight lifted and I was saying what
all right what is that what is that and
then as I thought about it I'm thinking
what am I not why do I feel like this
you know I just had a big smile on my
face and was you know walking around my
house and and thinking myself ah this
feels good what is this and then I
realized oh you're you're actually not
worried that one of your friends is
gonna die today which is a which was a
totally it's like I said it was
something that crept up on me and was
just there there's just part of being
over there and it felt good to to have
that weight come off but you know again
I think I dealt with it pretty decently
and you know did I get drunk with my
friends yeah well there was some
significant tu Boozer activities that
were were we're fun and we let off a lot
of steam and I think that's fine but
again you know what worries me about
saying that is that there's some people
that take that as like oh okay now I'm
cleared hot just to go and and get drunk
and get crazy and it's like no actually
you're not you've got to keep that in
check and especially from the guys that
are in leadership positions hey man you
got to keep a close eye and step back
and detach and look at the guys and say
okay I get it we're gonna let off some
steam
I get it we're gonna adjust back to the
real world but we need to make sure that
everyone is staying inside the box
and make sure that they're gonna come
back out of this thing okay because I
mean we all know it nowadays men the
vets veterans come home and that's a
hard transition to make from from combat
to you know the civilian world and and
even the world that you're talking about
going from being a Seawolf in the Wild
West coming back to your commanding
officer saying look you're not gonna get
away with that craft here and you know
we definitely had our share of little
stories like that from to you bruiser
where you know guys guys would not quite
be ready yet you know as a matter of
fact JP Danelle who is with me at
national on front my brother when he
came home when we came home he used in
another platoon got hurt they sent him
to our basic training school so buds
he's going to be a buds instructor
and he didn't last very long over there
because you can't take a guy that's 23
years old that just been through what JP
had been through and say okay now you're
gonna go go and be in charge of training
these guys that are trying to make it
through buds it wasn't a good fit yeah
and so I just you know luckily had
friends and was able to just pull him
over and he worked directly for me again
getting ready for the the more advanced
training and combat training which he
was perfect for but that was an example
of where you know I I had to look out
and say okay this is not a good job for
him right now
you know JP is already an intense an
intense guy and coming home from Ramadi
you know it was it was it was a tough
deployment he only lost friends and as a
young kid he wasn't ready to be teaching
these young you know he's looking at
these kids like you know you are you
kidding me I'm gonna I'm gonna freakin
decimate you guys and so I had to pull
him over to a little bit more canister
and my brother JP so you get oh so now
so now you you're staying in the Navy
that's it never a doubt in my mind and
you end up I mean you you end up doing
the anti-submarine warfare which is the
job that kind of unknown is that the job
that annoyed you we call it a so what
you were given a mission without the the
means to prosecute the mission and that
annoyed me and then and then you went on
to become a test pilot is that rise that
correct the steely-eyed granite jaw test
pilot and look at me now so so what is
that job like ah it's it's fascinatingly
you know I'm living proof that nothing
harms our that person more than too much
formal education but I get off on that
and it was brought home to me once when
we were having a raging party at her
home in Patuxent River Maryland when I
was there at the test center and most of
the guys that have a copy of Playboy
magazine on their night table a couple
of guys have gone back to take a leak in
our bedroom and found that I had some
technical reports they're mine and I
didn't hear the end of that for
for a long time but I enjoyed it I
enjoyed the technical aspects of it I
have often said there are only two
topics that are worthy of conversation
between men and that is flying and
fornication and you know I I lived to
fly
having said that since I retired I've
flown very little but at that point in
my life it was all about flying and it
was a wonderful experience the the
flying we did was not experimental fine
that was engineering flying we test out
weapons systems we test out new aircraft
I was fortunate to to lead one of the
three prongs of the the biggest
helicopter acquisition that the Navy's
made when they were looking for the new
lamps helicopter two of my great good
friends were were flying the Sikorsky
and the and the Boeing products and they
were pretty well through their test
program which took I think about a year
when Bell Helicopter piped up and says
hey we've got one too well they didn't
have a a really logical contender but
they needed somebody to go on down and
leave the test of that aircraft and that
was me and boy that was fun
you know you literally are flying the
test card that takes out to the edge of
the envelope and hey are you good enough
sure I'm good enough yeah just don't go
too far and don't bust your ass there's
a lot of investment that you're sitting
in right there that you want they want
you to keep in in one piece but no I I
thoroughly enjoyed it lifelong friends
there and just keep me to a story the
two guys that were flying the bowings
and sikorsky dear friends one of them
was a Naval Academy classmate and he and
I flew in Vietnam and the other guy
Greek is just a wonderful guy and still
a lifelong close friend well duck was
unfortunately fortunately for Hughes
became their chief test pilot he got out
of the Navy and was flying for Hughes
and was killed in a
and a horrible accident and Greek and I
sort of sort of closed ranks and decided
that we were going to try and send duck
off in good stead so if you're familiar
with San Diego now you know about the
point loma lighthouse and the area up
there that's where the family was
waiting Hughes had given us a 500 to
scatter the remains in that Greek took
it upon himself to do this now at this
time he probably had 2,500 flight hours
he knew his way around a helicopter he's
in his Navy blues he gets in the
aircraft
he's got the cremains in his lap and
they're flying out along well below the
the point on on out over the ocean and
he looks up and sees the family up there
and he's so emotionally wrought that he
reaches down and takes the lid off of
the cremains well if you've ever been in
a helicopter you know that it's not a
very stable place to have cremains and
immediately he said it was IFR inside
that cockpit with duck every and
fortunately the family didn't know what
was going on and everything came out
fine but Greek could call me up and said
hey I had to make mustard today and I
said yeah and he says yeah and when I
got my blues out I'm still brushing duck
off so yeah there's ways you you
accommodate that I always think of the
great good times that that duck and we
got a Greek and I had together and I
miss him sure I miss him all the time
but she life goes on sounds like he had
the final say it that way yeah yeah you
oh I see during the Iranian hostage
crisis what was that like that was
self-made you know yes we were the only
a helicopter out there that wasn't on
the large gray boats to actually fly the
mission that could could provide combat
search and rescue so we took full
advantage of that got the armament that
we thought we passing through Guam you
didn't like the sidearm I had so I went
on down to buy one I know it's going to
take two weeks and it took me about two
hours to get in touch with the local
authorities and I had my life sidearm on
going over the horizon which is sort of
silly you know I mean really you're
flying an overwater mission and you need
a said well you never can tell it's
always good to be prepared but at any
rate we'd go out there and and just
train for that when we weren't actually
out there in support of the the boats
we'd want an contraindicated it at 20 is
that this is how long you did 20 21 21
years and then you went off to the
civilian sector yesterday started
working a bunch of various jobs that's
right it started out in high-tech our
company had a professional staff of two
hundred sixty percent of whom were PhDs
and I had enough technical background
that I'd go out to a customer with one
or more of these PhDs and they'd make
their presentation and I'd say let me
think he was a doctor meant to say was a
great I'm being surrounded by smart
people it just is a lot of fun it can be
very frustrating at times then it's a
lot of fun yeah and we have a curious
insult in the teams which is someone
will ask you about a guy and the guy's
not a bad guy but some will say oh you
know he's he's a really easy really
smart guy which is common sense you
might not be the best leader we're you
know smart guy so yes it can get
frustrating hang around with people that
are super smart and then fine and when
did you move to Hawaii
14 years ago I spent five years in
arranged operations and then they
created a new position and for my last
five working years I was the
environmental manager for the Pacific
Missile Range my daughter when she
learned of that said dad you hate those
guys and I said yes Heather but now I'm
in a position to say no and I just had a
lot of fun you know the video the local
environment community great people that
they were not strong supporters of
military training and that that was my
cause to help them explain why we needed
to train out there and that we weren't
out to kill the whales yeah yeah and
then how long ago was it that you
retired retired about four years ago
that's retirement has been very very
good to DJ and I mean I got I got one
more quote that I that I that I wanted
to read because I know we've been going
at it for a bit here but uh this is this
is another quote this is a quote from
from a Vietnam Seal and here we go
not only does many a seal always life to
the sea Wolf's but the unit's often
operated together as a team very often
located at the same base of operations
we developed friendships that are still
alive today operating well outside
standing opera standard operating
procedures the sea Wolf's have lifted
seals out of enemy encirclement and I
have known them to land in a hot LZ to
lift out cache as too large for the
seals to pack out they also evacuated
our wounded when medevac helicopters
were not available most important they
were always there for us when we were
down in the mud and darkness the night
illuminated with red and green tracers
the VC behind every shadow many times
after we were out of danger they stayed
with us until we were safely extracted
in the middle of the river and out of
the range of enemy fire and
chief Barry Enoch who's a legendary seal
from SEAL team one Navy Cross recipient
and I think that that quote just really
exemplifies the the bond between seals
and sea Wolf's in like I said it was
something that I heard about as a young
seal and it's a bomb that still exists
when when I talk to the Vietnam seals
and it's a bond that's that's always
gonna be there and I'm into that
do you have any uh you know I know like
I said we've been at it for a while and
I like and like I told you before we
started I can sit I'll sit here I could
sit here and listen to you all day but
uh do you have any other you know any
other closing thoughts that you want to
that you want to mention hand salute
into the 44 that didn't make it back
with us anyone who hasn't been to the
wall
anybody who's served who hasn't been to
the wall you got to make that trip a
shout out again and I know it sounds
like a broken record but to the guys
that are responsible for getting me back
in one piece our Gunners great human
beings and to the guys I flew with eight
next time we'd get together the beers on
you yeah I should share with you that as
a technical person I have developed what
I call Raleigh's theorem and rally's
theorem says that all the truly great
ladies hook up with all the truly big
buffoons and stinky if you're out there
listening I sure am glad that you did
that love you more than porkchops baby
and well also thanks to your son Sean
for for connecting us and when he came
up and asked me as I go do you would you
have a CF on your podcast I'm like ah
let me think about that 4.2 seconds
absolutely so yeah thanks to Sean for
for connecting
and it's it's been an honor to sit here
and listen to you and thanks for what
you and all the Seawolves did for our
country for our Navy and specifically
thank you for the support that you and
your brothers gave to my brothers and my
forefathers on the ground in Vietnam
we'll never forget what you and your
brothers did I will never forget the
sacrifices of those those brave sea
Wolf's that made the ultimate sacrifice
for our freedom
amen and Dennis rally has has left the
building and obviously awesome to have
him on and incredible opportunity to
talk about this the sea Wolf's and go
check out this website
it's Sea Wolf org really cool website to
read through one of the coolest things
on it is I read that example of the Wolf
Graham they got all the wolf Grahams and
they're all just for yeah they're good
they're worth checking out they've also
got all the awards that well not they've
got the list of awards if they got the
Navy Cross Awards in there just an
awesome website so go check it out see
wolf dot org and with that if you want
to support you know yourself this
podcast etc echo what do you got stay on
the path okay
talk about jujitsu yes jujitsu get Agee
we know we're getting G's or gingy's do
we all know that yeah that's origin do
we know that yes I know that so go to
origin main com
that's where you get your key and rash
guards for jujitsu 100% bar none I'm
almost tempted to say don't even get any
other kind of gear or ration card I
would agree with that yeah boom 100%
also if you're warming up or cooling
down or just cruising they have joggers
yeah you got into the joggers yeah oh so
my son got some of the joggers which
he's totally stoked on I tried them on
yeah just to see it was so horrible
they are so not not not used situation
well here's the thing with joggers
depending on how you wear them for sure
but they're more of a should I put this
kind of acceptable they're kind of
form-fitting from time to time yeah
right so they're you know they're kind
of you know so little flap around so
they're form-fitting you in form-fitting
joggers yeah that I could see how that
could be a violation for sure but if
you're not Jocko joggers most
comfortable joggers in the world
probably in the history of joggers maybe
ever origin main origin joggers also we
got some supplements on there that you
can take you got joint warfare which
will keep your joints intact yeah yeah
krill oil the same thing kind of
universal substance yeah that's the
maintain that you I I went off the joint
warfare for a little while why Wow long
story long story being yeah I know laps
of discipline you know or nothing so I
just don't I'm not like compelled as
much oh don't you okay
you make it like a routine no it's like
that's just the thing I get up every day
yeah take it before I get I take krill
oil and and joint warfare when I wake up
in the morning in before I go to bed at
night period in the story every day yeah
like not even train that day still 100%
joint life area during that day but yeah
well discipline is not a hundred percent
because I don't take that every day I
take it when needed
yeah but I will say I've been using I
feel like that's a little bit of a
crutch right now cuz I've been using it
a lot before you can take it yeah you
can but no the joint warfare I like your
mindset I think I actually I think I
should incorporate that where it's just
not ever this house every day so with
the joint warfare I'll be like well you
know like it'll be in my mind not even
necessarily heavily but it'll be a my my
own did I train hard enough to warrant
like joint warfare kind of kind of
attitude
it's more
less like that so I wasn't feeling any
kind of inflation or pain or nothing so
I was like uh you know it's like so I
skipped it one day and then I sort it
you know it just wasn't in my mind sure
enough and I'm still lifting still doing
it still in the game
freaking elbow comes back because I get
elbow from impressive you know and I get
little elbow things
nothing terrible you just gotta warm up
more or whatever but Manny came back go
back just like they all the joint 100%
they just this is just the other day so
usually it takes a few days to like kind
of get back how's it feel right now it's
fine but when I start if I started to do
a push up like a Close Grip push up
right now I'll feel it probably maybe I
don't I don't know because it's been a
few days so that's joint warfare loyal
discipline and then got mocha which is
just the food that you need in your body
that's what it basically is yeah and it
tastes good and also for your kids you
got warrior kid milk strawberry and
chocolate they're both really good but
let's face it the strawberry is a whole
nother deal Brian is working on adult
strawberry milk will be coming out with
that can add you this yeah the regular
milk dark chocolate is good right yeah
after a certain percentage of what is it
what is it what makes dark chocolate
better right it's like a certain
percentage oh you took our life in life
yeah yeah because there's no sugar in it
if you just get straight dark chocolate
right but that's like 80% 80% that's
like the the thresholds let me this way
80% is as good when you get to 72%
you're like you're like oh that's just a
tasty you know you're just eating
dessert 80 percents not quite it still
gives you a chocolate satisfaction but
it's not like the same low ingredients
right if you eat two squares of 80
percent chocolate
you won't desire more if you ate to eat
two squares of 72 percent chocolate you
like up have a little bit more yeah just
like that tasty okay perfect so so the
the Mulk
with adult monk my question to you in
your opinion your joke discipline
opinion if I put a chunk because I can
last night I put this junk there's chunk
I don't know why he was there was there
chunk of chocolate
it wasn't a tea person in the blender I
didn't put the whole thing I broke off a
little piece so is maybe like the size
of two you know the little baby Snickers
bars two of those I would say that's how
big the chunk this block of chocolate -
the baby Snickers yeah that's pretty big
yeah it was a big monk shake though it's
like three scoops okay you know like you
know the 30 ounce yeah the mugs that we
have for anyway
put it in with the peanut butter
chocolate milk and it enhanced it
oh yeah well of course so the question
is is like how much of a violate like if
it's 80% chocolate dark 80% dark
chocolate but you didn't put any
presenter I know
but sugar trucker what I did I didn't do
I'm saying theoretically
if I did 80% or more chocolate
that's good that's still within the
confines I'd say you're you know in the
path in the game right so you're in the
game in on the path okay at 80% so if
when we come across 80% chocolate let's
add that just collectively let's add
that and see how we all feel about that
that's what I think
sure you get the little chips at the
bottom of the cup - it's pretty cool
check also I just talked to a guy
strawberry or for the warrior kid mm-hmm
Moke if your kid is lactose intolerant
you put them on the almond milk right so
get some of that
do you also if you want to represent on
the path chuckle the store it's called
chuckle store where you can get shirts
hats hoodies tank tops more rash guards
recommended still within within the
confines of being in the game our rash
guards as well if yeah if you want to
represent in the wild on the path and in
the wild the same time jaw closed or
dot-com so you can get some cool stuff
all Jaakko approved all of it women's
stuff on there is by the way there is
counterfeit choco stuff yeah but here's
the thing about the cockpit here's the
thing about the counterfeit once they're
like ah be like if you all you have to
do here I dig it like you'll see a cool
design
that seems new because that's really the
the what do you call it the visceral not
visceral that's negative right like that
your immediate response is like all new
design on Amazon or wherever these
counterfeits
exist you see the new design so you kind
of okay cool and you in your in your
haste you click on it but here's the
thing if you just stop for one second
you can be aggressive but not foolhardy
right yeah so you take this one moment
to recognize the design you'll know
there's violations all through every
single design on there first off the
font is like that completely wrong fun
it's completely wrong
then I saw one like the good one right
mmm that's on like you know one of these
one of these websites that you can go to
and you submit your PDF or JPEG and it
generates a shirt for you uh-huh it's
like it's a super cheap thing so there's
one available forget what it's called
but it's one of those where it's like
obviously cheap and the designs wrong
it's backwards
ours is backwards the good sets is
backwards it's how it's supposed to be
oh there's one's all frontwards like
just some person who didn't pay
attention yeah he's trying to do it it's
real obvious if you take that second to
notice it though so the counterfeit ones
mmm you know there you go just look out
for the counterfeit ones yeah yeah
they're out there also do you won't get
counterfeit ones at choco starcom
correct yes actually actually also
chuckle white tea is they're counterfeit
chocolate white tea there is not yes so
that's no it's gonna be a lot harder to
come on that's that you'd have to put
some effort into that one yeah you'd
have to get labels done I would actually
kind of impressed you slightly just in
your mode of getting after it would be
high level yeah cuz it's not easy to
make tea no not easy to make cans of tea
no and it's not easy to deadlift eight
thousand pounds
unless you've been drinking your tea and
some of that organic - by the way
certifying just sayin also subscribe to
the podcast if you haven't already on
iTunes and stitcher
in Google Play and wherever you listen
to podcasts because there's a lotta
guest apps there's a lot of podcasts to
yeah yeah and if you're listening to
this one tank in a way it's kind of man
thanks well definitely thanks there's
also the warrior kid podcast yeah which
is getting a lot of hype right now yeah
why because we talked about it on the
last two podcasts go hear people kind of
recognize and they didn't this is the
thing I'm not real good at the whole
like like hey everyone look at what I'm
doing that's not really sure you know
I'm like hey there's a podcast if you
want to check it out check it out so
with the I posted it and talked about it
and so a bunch of people went and check
out the warrior kid podcast the feedback
is awesome and I appreciate it and also
if you want to check out some warrior
kids stuff you can check out Irish Oaks
ranch calm where Aiden who's a warrior
kid is making soap on his farm just for
real and if you want to get some of that
soap Irish Oaks ranch calm that way you
can follow the motto of Aiden's soap and
that motto is stay clean so check that
one out also we got a YouTube channel
which is called Jocko podcast and that's
where these videos are of this podcast
if you want to see what Denis Rowley
looks like how tall how tall he is can
you tell that from a video where he's
sitting down he was kind of going out of
frame like yeah like sit up yeah so yes
he's good yeah he's a big dude full of
Aloha by the way full of Aloha but yeah
if you want to see what what Denis
Raleigh looks like and you can come on
there you can also see echoes enhanced
videos as he likes to call him he thinks
it's an enhancement and he adds stuff to
him you think it takes it away takes
away from the raw message actually I
heard that yeah oh we're that people
have actually told you that well I don't
agree with it up tomato okay well
totally changed my attitude is the is
the Mikey in the Dragons video okay that
video is sick the video that you made it
and that video I said to myself even
this is more powerful even like you know
you never really think about well you
think about it but like the background
music like when
it says the King dies there's like jello
kicks in the background of like somber
yeah
well that that is a good point and you
are kind of advanced in your thinking
because really to put kind of put it
kind of precisely the goal is it's not
necessarily to be like hey what's the
background music supposed to be it's
like what's the feeling supposed to be
and you know certain instruments music
or whatever will provide certain
feelings and you know that's kind of the
goal to line them up that's it man you
recognize this so that video has
definitely impressed upon me that videos
can have a positive impact and
positively enhance to use your term
what's going on with the words that are
in the video yeah but what about if I
put like the walls crumbling and
crashing down see and you see that
overall this explodes like one of those
people that got carried away with CGI on
that video yeah which I you know you
gotta explore the boundaries yes and
sometimes you go to I see on a recent
video that I did I'm not gonna say which
one but I did the same thing but now
with crumbling and crashing noises and
effects I did it with lens flares
you know lens flare is right oh yes
optical lens flare somebody put some
light in front of their camera yeah well
it's the the aberrations or I don't know
whatever the word you want to use that
that a light going directly at the
camera will create these yeah yeah you
know little and you can do it on purpose
right it's like a look it's like an epic
look when you get what's called an
anamorphic lens it kind of does this
thing it compresses it to the SEC kind
of thing and then when you when you to
put in layman's terms basically when you
put what video did you do this on I
can't tell you now we're not gonna watch
all my damn you know watch all the
videos you tell me but here's why I
don't want to say it because now people
would be paying attention to it and
they'll be like well you're right
because okay not to go into a whole long
thing but okay so there's a guy named JJ
Abrams he's a director and I think a
writer too but anyway he does he did
like the new Star Trek movies and did
the new Star Wars you know he's like
kind of a sci-fi guy and he got a lot of
he got a
people had an issue with the amount of
lens flares he allowed in Star Trek the
newer stuff so clear everywhere I
thought it looked dope man
I really liked that look but he got a
lot of you know a lot of for it
nonetheless I don't want to be in that
same boat with these videos with that
particular video that I'm talking about
so if they don't notice then good if so
in that zoom scene I'm gonna go post
about it nonetheless psychological
warfare 2 which is an album of tracks
where I tell you what you should do to
push through the moment of weakness and
that's all we're gonna say about that ok
it works with a hundred percent
certainty I'll add that are you still
batting 100% right now well hey I'm
gonna call I'm gonna call oh yeah oh
hundred percent every single time I've
ever usually here the thing I haven't
used it recently because it's like are
you scared of it I need it I don't have
many moments of weakness nowadays see
I'm like forged in the fire of
discipline no transgressions are you
trying to set yourself up to make a
video with flare for your reporting back
to you my current status on my
discipline no less I haven't had to use
it recently so yeah I mean doesn't
matter if every single time that I've
used it it yeah it helps like what I'm
gonna do listen to you telling me and
then like oh good you know to me just
making the effort to open my ears to you
is already already like already know on
the way they're like power through yes
exactly right
Jack so you know 100% on that one in my
experience also on a very uh pre-workout
on it fitness gear is that on it comm
they got a lot of cool stuff on there a
lot of good stuff so if you want to
improve enhance very increased variables
increase stuff in your workout if it's
getting boring or something like this go
to on it calm get some get something
from there like kettle bells or rings or
battle ropes I think if you add one or
more of those things into your work
it'll be enhanced greatly results wise
it's my opinion predict also books what
do we got well first of all we got Mikey
and Dragons told you about the video go
watch the video and then you'll want to
get the book why cuz that goat did a
really good job and thanks because the
book is legit I might love to say that
about my own Booker's that make me
arrogant ya know from that I've been
told it's legit everyone appreciates
book and a bunch of people have now
started posting reviews on Amazon which
is very cool I appreciate it
I've read them and I'll read some next
time live but uh yeah so so Mikey in the
Dragons here's the deal is it sold out
at this moment in time yes will it be
sold out when you hear this probably not
actually it's probably we got more books
coming in I'm getting imprinted as
quickly as they can possibly print them
and I apologize for not correctly
estimating how many books everyone would
buy that is my fault and I apologize for
it but if you do want Mikey and the
Dragons order it as soon as you can so
that you can get it as quickly as
possible also the way the warrior kid
books where the warrior kid and marks
mission those books are good for kids
and adults and really anyone and you
know just got done talking to talking to
Dennis rally downstairs and he's like oh
yeah I read those books they're awesome
so he's a he's a what I don't know how
how old he is but he's a Vietnam veteran
pilot and he read warrior kids and was
was down for the cost that's weed you
sit down for the cause because I was
thinking in my head down for the cause
yeah well he is clearly yeah you know
down for the cause if this Michaels
freedom feel manual good one upstanding
one acts really I think so again and I
said this before I'm say it again
because this is a constant thing it's
like one of those things like a manual
like an actual manual for life right but
so ok you said that I get it but yeah
you refer to it that's what you do it's
like a reminder and we do this all the
time by the way but this is a good one -
just remember because that's part of the
the actually it's the majority of the
challenge right there is to remember
this stuff
like say hey you shouldn't freaking
drink a soda right now with your sushi
don't do that you know that already but
if it's just part of the habit it's like
boom you might forget cuz you were
thinking about some other stuff you know
some edits or whatever that you had to
do say so you got that manual there this
time and you just refer to it kind of
maybe even daily
semi daily I recommend daily daily and
you just remember all this stuff just
keeps you on the path man that one isn't
print by the way there's plenty of them
so you can order that one and it's a
good Christmas gift yeah for people that
you know who needs it in your world you
don't I mean and I don't think it's
insulting by the way if someone is
offended by it just get him to crack it
open yeah cuz they'll realize like hey
this isn't meant to offend this is meant
to build yeah and actually you know what
now that you think of it that book isn't
like extreme ownership might be that
kind of book that if you get it what's
up for someone they'll be like like what
are you sure you know like will elicit
what do you call defensiveness yeah but
the Field Manual won't cause like first
when you first see you're not hot it's
awesome just item soon saying like
looking at it but it's like yeah it's
like a cool like Field Manual it doesn't
scream like you need to take
responsibility for stuff that's why I
mean just you don't get that feel but
even even if that person might feel that
maybe you got to do with like a certain
type of card or something soon as they
yeah thank you for everything you've
ever taught me Jack well speaking of
extreme ownership there's extreme
ownership and there's that I caught amia
leadership both books there about
leadership and they are available of
course and those are those are books
that will pragmatically teach you how to
lead that's all there is to it
National on Front speaking of leadership
that's our leadership consultancy do we
solve problems to leadership it's me
Lafe babban JP Danelle Dave Burke Flynn
Cochran Mike Sorelli and Mike bimah
go to a salon front comm if we want us
to come to your business and align your
leadership or you want us to come and do
a keynote speech go to a salon front
calm and get the details there the
muster is coming up 2019 video soon to
be released it's gonna be in Chicago
Denver and Sydney yes three months to
Sydney Australia are you familiar with
that area yes yeah so Chicago Sydney and
Denver
check out extreme ownership calm that's
where we'll post the details all of them
have sold out and all of them will sell
out you might not think that in
Australia we're gonna sell out but we
will so you've seen all of them have
sold out in the past in the past yes no
sorry yes they haven't these ones
haven't sold out yet but they will so
register early everyone down under mmm
we know when I was in Brizzy sure I
wasn't Brizzy and we did a little book
signing I did a little book signing and
there was people from all over Australia
there
Brizzy did you know when you're in
Brizzy hmm that the australians tend to
do that very thing with words
they'll shorten them and put e or OS
there for sure you know yeah yes so the
Aussies do that with their seats there
Ozzy's boom yeah yeah well there you go
I kind of incorporated that when I've
been there twice and yeah I noticed that
and I liked it
the first SAS guy I had worked with you
know what his name was well there was
two the first one's name was Duchy Duchy
was his horny
I had four there was a long Dutch name
and the other one's name was Tom oh and
then Nicky right
so yeah 100% we're batting a hundred
yeah bad a thousand I was doing it well
I guess what would be called a
mini-documentary one of the times I went
there and one of the guys name is Jason
row big it's a black belt under Hickson
Gracie was with him and he you the way
he did explain what feels like hey what
are you guys doing he'd be like oh we're
making a little dock Oh for you know for
this thing or whatever and some people
understood oh they do
I was like doc I like that it's good
yeah man so yeah I incorporate that and
do you think so yeah Australia will be
down there Chicago Denver also we have
EF overwatch now if you're looking to
bring little experienced and tested
leaders into your organization on the
civilian side we've got military spec
ops and combat aviators that are leaders
that have been trained and have been
tested and they're moving into the
civilian sector to come and help your
company go to EF over watch.com
and if you want to keep you know sort of
kicking it with us we're available on
the interwebs on Twitter on Instagram
and on Facebook e Baja EKKO is a deco
Charles and I am at Jocko willing and
thanks to all our military personnel out
there that are out there protecting our
freedom and to all the vets that have
served and have protected our great
nation and a special thanks to Hal 3 the
Seawolves for doing what you did 24
hours a day to support and save troops
on the ground thanks to all of you and
of course the Dennis rally thanks for
coming on it's amazing to meet you and
thanks for sharing your history and the
history of the Seawolves
with us can't say that enough thank you
thanks to police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs
correctional officers border patrol
first responders of all kinds thanks for
holding the line for us 24 hours a day
here at the homefront and to everyone
else out there if you're feeling a
little outgunned by the world think
about think about those words scramble
the Seawolves and then go out on the
attack no matter the weather or the
environment or the enemy fire you've got
problems going hot
and get after it and until next time
this is echo and Jocko out